here we are born to the king
and that is no lie for a while in this
movie i was like is this a highlander
movie that's totally not called
highlander
but it's totally a highlander movie that
i didn't know about it's not a
highlander movie but
i suppose that's really useless
information for the intro it's what i
thought of them
it's kind of like eyeliner it's like a
passive highlander it's highlander with
no beheadings
[Music]
anyhow so the old guard is a movie that
came straight to netflix because
2020. at first it looked like super
special ops
then one whips out a sword and i was
like son that's
weird i didn't know anything about this
movie which i am kind of really digging
this whole going into movies without
seeing trailers thing
turns out that sword has a point and
purpose because everyone here well
they're much older than they look they
get gunned down well they just
heal right up like wolverine and they
come back to life because they are
immortal they have inside them blood of
kings they have no rival
no man can be their equal so take me to
the future of you all
then we have chiwetel ejiofor kind of
sniffs out who and what they are and we
have this one
oh man if ever there was some silicon
valley
villain looking [ __ ] this is the
guy i mean no disrespect to the actor
i'm just saying one look at this guy and
he looks like that morally compromised
silicon valley [ __ ] he's just
probably gonna do some shady [ __ ] to
capture these people i feel like i'm
being kind of a dick
i don't mean to it's kind of like brad
duraff you know like i love brad duraff
but if brad durf gets cast in a roll you
know he's probably going to be some
creepy [ __ ] it really is
praise for the casting because you know
he wants to cure aging and so he's like
oh there's a key so you have charlie
starring in their crew and actually a
really compelling story among them and
why they group together and then you
have this new person who's like oh i'm
immortal i'm just figuring this out
so that she finds her a lot of
compelling elements to this movie and
that's actually what drew me to it the
action is pretty cool yeah but the
connection among the characters
that's really it's the meat and bones of
this entire story it's the bone marrow
of it and i for one
i really dug it you feel the connection
between them you get the fact that these
people have known each other for
centuries a couple of them were in a
relationship and it's like you get how
strong this relationship is which
boy that's a man that's patience right
i'm amazed when people make it
30 years these two have been together
since the crusades but one of the things
this
story touches on is how long life
and connection with connection
let me start over a long life without
connection with people is a really
lonely one and it starts to drive you a
little nuts
all that stuff compelled me also i mean
the fact that charlize theron just
completely eradicates people in a fight
i just like it when people are like i
am so old like conor mcleod of the clan
macleod
i've just always loved the fact that
people go toe-to-toe with someone it's
like great you've been training for 20
years they've been training for 2000 or
so
though in the end john wick could still
take any of them on and the movie had
some solid humor a couple times so she's
really chuckled i mean
it's violence humor you know when people
are dead and it's like that's kind of
funny you know what i'm talking about
you all laughed when marvin got shot in
the face in pulp fiction i was
it wasn't that funny but there are a
couple scenes i was like oh but that's
funny and actually it's by the end when
the whole
vision and scope of this whole story
comes together
it kind of re i liked it it kind of
reminded me of a show that
i can't tell you what the show is
because it kind of spoils this story but
has nothing to do with
highlander-ish immortals but it's a it's
a show that was canceled in its first
season that i really liked and
it has that kind of thing in there that
kind of human connection element you
know and i have a soft spot for that
stuff
fact is also when i'm watching it it
kind of feels like a straight to netflix
movie which i
imagine it wasn't planned on being a
straight to netflix movie this being the
final stages of sim city all the
disasters are getting thrown at us and
now we're here this is 2020 the final
stage
of the simcity in the matrix but there
is like when i try to think of the fact
that if i saw this in a movie theater in
which i had
new movies week to week back to back
this movie probably would have just
gotten lost in the background but as a
straight to netflix movie it actually
really stands out to me advantageous for
this movie because it was trending
number one on netflix at least
last night when i watched it would it be
trending number one
in the weekend box office if it came out
in the movie theaters
probably not and that is interesting at
least for me how things feel
different you know if i have to go to
the movie vader and watch a movie
i if a movie feels like a straight to
netflix movie in the movie theater that
stands out to me as a negative but if it
feels that way
while it's on netflix it's just
perfectly fine i don't know if you're
that way but apparently i'm that way
that is to say
in the end for this movie i hadn't heard
about until i did
this week i actually enjoyed this movie
i had a good time with it it has solid
intrigue in terms of its world-building
lore
among its characters that are intriguing
immortal types that you want to know
more about but the movie actually
doesn't
dump all the knowledge and information
on you and i'm intrigued i want to see
the sequel i want to see more from this
universe because it actually hooked me
with its setup and build up
that is to say i had a good time with
this movie no alcohol required all right
so the old guard have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you